despite the hulls of protests criticisms
and warnings the Sri Lankan government
approved its new internet law on
Wednesday the Online safety Bill sets up
a commission which can jail people for
up to 5 years for Content it decides is
illegal protesters outside Parliament
said it's an attempt by President Vikram
MinGa to silence his
critics no matter what laws are brought
against people's rights whatever
repression is rolled out even if people
are dragged to jail one by one and the
police are deployed we can't be put down
you can't stop the people from coming
forward the bill bans what would be
deemed as false statements that threaten
national security health public order or
provoke riots and religious divisions it
also prevents false reports causing
Mutiny of the military and allarm or
fear to the public the government has
said a Crackdown on online abuse of
women and children and pornography are a
key factor of the new laws the Supreme
Court received 46 petitions against the
bill and ruled that more than half its
closers needed to be changed the
government
agreed I will present all new proposals
at the next cabinet meeting after that
they will be announced I don't think
anyone will challenge those proposals in
the Supreme Court because all parties
have agreed to those proposals we will
bring them as amendments to the act on a
future date local and international
rights groups have condemned the bill
the UN asked for significant revisions
saying it can be used to suppress
dissenting voices think about the damage
that you're causing in your petty
interest in your petty efforts to
maintain power at any cost think of the
damage you're doing to this country
think of the international the damage
the the reputation of this country
internationally think of the damage
you're doing to potential investors the
Asia internet Coalition which includes
Tech giants like Google Apple and meta
said the bill is unworkable and would
undermine potential growth and foreign
investment in Sri Lanka's digital
economy while the government insists the
legislation is needed to protect
communities and individuals many say the
Online safety will will be a weapon not
a shield in government hands n Fernandez
Al jazer
[Applause]
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer